we're joined now by the conservative
back venture Sir John Redwood lovely to
have you on the program thank you for
coming on this morning now you're a
member of the conservative growth group
and we hear you're developing some
policy proposals to take to the treasury
in the coming weeks what do you want to
see
well we want to see sensible targeted
tax cuts that will boost self-employment
boost investment help solve the problem
of recruiting and retaining doctors and
other skilled staff
and we'll add to the idea of growth
we're very pleased that the Prime
Minister and the new Chancellor have now
got growth as one of their big five aims
and indeed out of the five aims three of
the aims are economic and they're all
really related to growth that is exactly
the right thing to do but we're urging
them to do rather more and not to rule
out tax rate Cuts so we think they're
going to be crucial particularly to
boost investment otherwise we're going
to have a very poor year for investment
which will lead to a very disappointing
outturn on growth we've just seen what
the threat of high taxes is doing with
AstraZeneca transferring a very
important investment to Ireland
what specific tax cuts would you like to
see them
well there are quite a lot
um of targeted ones I think first of all
the self-employed getting a very bad
deal I think we should reverse the 2017
and 2021 changes to so-called ir35 you
want to promote more self-employment
make it easier for people to get into
self-employment that is the quickest way
to expand capacity then I think we need
to look at business taxes I don't think
the corporation tax rate increase will
raise the money the treasury in the
overall think it will all the evidence
is in the past when conservative
governments had the courage to cut the
corporation tax rate never a popular
move it raises more money it's the wage
tax business more than we've just seen
from AstraZeneca what what a big impact
going the other way can have on very
crucial developments in the Life
Sciences area in this case which is one
of the government's targets for
improvement I also think we need to cut
taxes where the tax itself is causing
strain on people's budgets or companies
budgets and it's creating a attack
subsidy Circle Merry-Go-Round which is
very damaging on the Public Accounts and
on the economy and why do we still
impose that on domestic fuel when
domestic fuel is too expensive and then
give people bigger subsidies cut out the
middle man and woman and take the tax
down why do we charge heavy energy using
businesses the highest carbon taxes of
anywhere in the major economies of the
world and then get forced into having to
pay them substances because they're
losing so much money so we need to
remove some of those taxes on energy at
a time of an energy crunch with very
high energy prices
you speak about the tax cuts that we
want to see and I'm just trying to work
out who we is you know how many of your
colleagues agree with you on this
well the the greatest group that is
gathering strength as we speak I think
uh I'm not aware by helping to whip the
growth group but uh and there are dozens
of conservative MPS who take the view uh
that the growth strategy the government
has headlined needs some more positive
measures behind it and I think you'll
find probably a majority of the
conservative back bench would agree with
what I'm saying today that they want
targeted tax cuts and then there will be
a range of views on which the best
targeted tax cuts to choose I think the
majority definitely believes that you
don't get growth without more realistic
tax levels and I think many are very
worried that Britain is in danger of
becoming uncompetitive because of the
higher taxes the government is wishing
to impose and we've had a good record in
past years for making ourselves a bit
more tax competitive and if you want to
see what lower taxes does and how it
transforms an economy and increases the
revenues just look across the Irish
State Republic of Ireland at the same
time there is a proportion out of
business because they've got the lowest
corporation tax of the advanced world
you say if you want to see what low
taxes does you should look at Ireland
but some would say if you want to look
what unfunded tax cuts do you can look
at the last mini budget by Liz truss
where you know the economy was really
wounded by it the bank of England even
had to step in with emergency measures
to stop a run on pensions I mean you
can't surely be proposing to do the same
thing just a few months later
well of course not I don't want to
repeat the mistakes of the bank of
England and the treasury made over that
period but of course sorry I'm just
going to jump in I just want to jump in
because you say there specifically the
mistakes that the bank of England and
the treasury made so you think it was
the bank of England and the treasury who
made the mistakes not the unfunded tax
cuts themselves
well it's very odd idea that some funded
tax cuts same time as that um tax change
which I think would produce more Revenue
than the obr and traditional forecasts
had we seen them that would have
suggested uh we had doubled the amount
in extra spending so why don't you blame
the unfunded spending increases if you
think it was deficit it did it but if
you actually look at what happened in
the markets the the bond market the
worried everybody was falling well
before the mini budget statement for the
simple reason that the bank of England
was talking it down the banks said these
bonds are far too high we're going to
sell a load of bonds to get the prices
of the bonds down we want the long-term
interest rates to rise so the bank of
England for policy reasons decided to
sell off the bond market and then it got
out of hand because the bank of England
clearly didn't understand the precarious
position of many Pension funds including
its own pension fund which was buying
far more guilts than it could afford to
pay for and that and of course it
rightly stepped in and showed that it
could turn the market on a six months
when it needed to at the same time
though it's the markets who reacted
wasn't it I mean they are pretty
emotionless things they Market they just
look at the what's in front of them
well the markets on the Monday and
Tuesday when we had the serious sell-off
in Britain that wasn't matched in
America the previous week America had to
sell off the same reasons as well it was
all about the ldi funds and and it
wasn't about quasi-quarting's mini
Budget on the Monday and Tuesday it was
people saying there is no point in
buying bombs or even holding bombs
because everybody's a seller because all
these funds needed to sell bombs to
raise cash
to meet all the margin calls that were
coming in because the bonds have fallen
in price and where you have a lot of
pension firms that owned four or five
six times the amount of bond that they'd
actually paid for they face very big
bills when the price fell so I'm really
interested to talk to you because
obviously it comes after the Liz truss
um piece in the Sunday Telegraph where
she blamed the powerful economic
establishment for what happened you
obviously was the key backer of Liz
trust do you speak to her March what do
you think her take is on the current
direction of the conservative party
well I mean I've obviously read her
essay in the Telegraph and I've had a
chat to us since then
um she does rightly identify the ldi
problems on the Monday and Tuesday as
being the main difficulty that we face
with the long-term interest rates she
hasn't gone quite as far as I've just
gone because she could have pointed out
that the bank of England on the
Wednesday showed that not only had it
created the problem but it knew how to
solve the problem very glad it did solve
the problem I agreed with their action I
think they could have done it just by
words they probably didn't have to buy
the extra bonds but buying the extra
bombs made sure that they could get the
market up again and I'm pleased that
they've now told us they've sold those
bonds of
profits went back up uh went the One
prices went back up and the interest
rates went back down a bit when the bank
wanted them to and that was the question
um was also about trying to be a little
bit forward-looking as well and I'm just
interested to know what do you think
trust's take is on the future direction
or the current direction of the party
well I suggest you interview less trust
I thought you wanted to know my views on
the economy and I didn't expect some
serious points about how you get growth
and in order to get growth you need to
understand that if you cut certain tax
rate right soften the ones that are
unpopular with the left you get much
more Revenue the wage tax the rich more
is to set tax rates that will make them
stay in pay the way to tax companies
more is to have competitive tax rates so
more companies stay here invest here or
come here and as we saw when when Sasha
Lawson for example cut top rates attacks
the rich paid an awful lot more and more
rich people came when I was born cut
cooperation tax over a period of years
the revenues went up they didn't fall so
my main message to the the transfer is
if you want growth you have to have
lower rates it doesn't mean you're short
changing the accounts it means you're
finding the smart way to attach to tax
the rich and tax companies rather more
than it is the rich and the companies of
course have got the money but they don't
necessarily have to pay tax here
the um the polling is pretty Dreadful
frankly for your party right now at one
uh poll out this week suggested if there
was an election now you've been second
place behind the SNP and of course I
know we have to take these things with a
large pinch of salt but are you
concerned that if your party doesn't
change direction there'll be a Wipeout
of course I'm concerned about the
current polling and it tells you
something about public mood but I think
the public is still with me and being
impatient to get on with the good news
and I think the Prime Minister was
identified the right three main
priorities the the waiting lists the
illegal immigration and the economy and
of the three things you said about the
economy the borrowing will come down if
we grow more uh as a percentage GDP and
inflation is going to come down because
it's a very tough physical monetary
squeeze on thanks to recent bank and
treasury action so it's all about growth
and that's why I repeat that you've got
to have a growth strategy indeed that
would reinforce the counter-inflation
strategy why do we have inflations we
don't have enough capacity in this
country why is energy so dear well we're
not producing enough of our own is part
of the reason there are lots of projects
out there that could get us more oil and
gas from the North Sea get on with them
government and set taxes that mean that
people will want to invest there we
obviously need a lot more capacity in
electricity production and routing
electricity around the country again
that this has to be balanced investment
where people can make money get on with
it and you will find lower taxes will
help you do that
okay thank you very much indeed always
uh Keen to hear your own views on this
so good to have you on the program